[Music]
now we all love grilled cheese i grew up
with it that was cheese on toast
but there's something quite amazing for
a grilled cheese especially when you
have
these incredible cheesies
a romano with pepper berry and
asiago beautiful i mean really beautiful
to do
the ultimate grilled cheese with this is
a dream come true
so i'm gonna just cut nice big long
slices so i can take off
the rind easily okay and those pepper
berries is gonna make the cheese
a little bit spicy look at that there i
mean
so beautiful and then with the
asiago again down
and literally cut off
the rind and then from there
get the slice and just go in half again
let's look at these nice
long luscious almost like
sort of mini bricks of cheese
now look at that and that pepper berry
is incredible
now the bread the singapore about a
great grilled cheese
is to make sure the bread is not too
thin
look at that beautiful locally
baked country bread
now from there a bit butter
okay and always butter heavily on the
outside
you'll see why especially when you get
that nice
crispy texture again
cover it with butter
okay we'll season the outside
with some salt and then from there
layer your cheese
instead of almost tailor-making in a way
that it becomes
somewhat almost it
to the bread and the secret behind this
grilled cheese
is a little bit of kimchi homemade
kimchi
which is going to give a nice spicy
texture
to that incredible cheese now
the acidity in this kimchi
is incredible but once it's been cooked
breathtaking fold that over and then
from there
push that down we're going to stick that
in the oven
look a beautiful fireplace over there
[Applause]
nice and warm touch of olive oil in
beautiful and then from there
get the temperature up
just lightly starting to smoke
rest on the side push that down nice
lift up and there she goes
now as she cooks start putting some
weight on there
and just pushing that down
push that down that way it's nice and
crispy
beautiful two minutes each side
and then once you've colored both sides
back out
and just place your spatula on top
and push down that helps to get the
cheese nicely melted
incredible the kimchi
with that incredible cheese especially
that pepper berry
it's just gonna be a wonderful
combination and also it just helps
elevate the flavor
that beautiful grilled cheese
take that out turn that over
is cracking away beautiful
the cheese is melted and this
here how crispy that is
beautiful look at that
oh my goodness me so i say
half again
oh my god
oh my god that's incredible
that pepper berry spicy
the acidity of that kimchi and that
bread
cooked in the open fire
wow it was so good it almost makes me
feel like
i want to move to tasmania that
is delicious let me know in the comments
what you think of that amazing dish and
if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or
on the natgio app